I'm tall I am tall I am tall I am tall I
am tall I am tall I am tall
all right so I feel like obviously the
question would be what's everyone's
height yeah I'm gonna start I'm on that
I'm 6'5
I'm six two Jesus I'm six three I'm six
one I'm six one I'm six two oh period
what I love it okay I feel like we
should all be friends
wait can I just say when I was coming in
like I was so scared I couldn't see
anything and I'm always looking for like
things to avoid when I'm walking my
biggest fear was just I don't want to
hit anything yeah right it's so
embarrassing I'm very unaware of like my
feet can we do shoe sizes as well oh
yeah yeah men's 12. I'm a woman's 11 and
then men's 9.5 yeah I'm the same as her
I'm a I'm a women's 11 and a man well I
guess it depends on the shoe yeah I'm
women's 11 men's nine and a half same uh
women's 12 I don't know men's size
women's 11 men's nine I'm a women's 10.
here do like theater in high school
like the mom or like yeah the funny
character the funny character
that's my fear like I want to do acting
but I'm like oh never ever have that
experience sometimes shorter girls have
a higher voice so I was like if someone
has a really high voice I feel like
that's gonna give it away but also like
seeing diversity in Heights from
relationships is nice like the person
I'm seeing is shorter than me and people
are always giving me crap for it me too
what's the height difference
um he's five nine um when I'm six months
five eleven and I'm six two so three
inches do you guys like have any like
cut offs like you would only date this
sure nah I did for a bit um but I was
like you know what I'm raising my
standards now like you gotta be this
tall to ride this ride
like having that like being like oh they
have to be this high you're missing out
probably on just a lot of people oh yeah
do you feel like you can't wear like
shoes I want to talk about heels I
typically I don't like wearing heels
anyway so it's like if I wear them it's
mainly for modeling or for like
different you know I'll be doing what I
do but it's like I don't want to stand
out even more I mean I'm a flat sport I
love my sandals I love my sneakers right
now yep you know what I mean like you
have my toes done like pull some fits
with some sandals and like cute flats
yeah I just feel like I'm like I'm
already six two I might as well be six
five literally six that's the first
thing they noticed so oh for me I like
platforms I like heels what is a quote
that people always say to you but nobody
can have the same answer so I'm gonna go
okay
like wow you're tall like they say like
oh yeah no way I'm sorry all right no
those generic one's like oh what's the
weather up like there that's like
literally when you're like Elementary
School yeah yeah literally do you play
basketball do you like what sport do you
play yeah yeah yeah yeah foreign she
didn't really talk very much she was in
an earlier round where you don't really
have much to go off of but Vibes or like
it's a waste if I'm not playing that
sport yeah yes yes I'm like I'm sorry
I'm literally a klutz I don't think you
want me no literally like the basketball
coach my high school was like just stand
there and oh
an athlete oh I'm a basketball player
but I used to play volleyball in school
and I didn't swim yeah but nowadays I
fly trapeze oh my goodness
oh whoa that's sick it's really cool
that's scary it'll be tough to be tall
because like you have a lot of body
there it's actually better to be taller
foreign
[Music]
Ty getting voted out first was shocking
because being tall is the first thing
that people see in my daily life and so
for people to believe that I wasn't tall
was a first for me I have a question
like what's everyone's ethnic background
and are your parents tall
um I'm white and yeah both of my parents
are taught my mom is six foot and my dad
is 6'3 and my brother's six six so a
little tall family I'm Mexican my mom's
five seven my dad's six four and my 15
year old brother six three wow okay
my mom is five she likes to say she's
five nine but she's not she's like five
eight and three fourths and my dad is
like six foot
um but Mike I I get my height from my
mom's side of the family so I have
cousins and they're like six six and six
nine and I had like a great great
grandmother that's like seven one oh my
God but it's like all on my mom's side
so that's where I get my height from she
was going into a lot of detail about her
fam only something like the mole would
do is just be very very detailed than
necessary and I think that's what most
Liars do oh and I'm black I'm sorry
my mom's Korean my dad's white and
people always are like oh it must be
like your white side where you get your
height from or something but actually my
Korean side's really tall my uncle's
over six foot I've got cousins that are
over six foot my doctor thought I would
you know cap out at 5 11 that I just
kept going
I admittedly fibbed during the group
round about like saying that a lot of my
family is tall because I thought that it
might be suspicious I'm black and my mom
is five seven on a good day and my dad
like wants to believe that he's six
three I don't think he is right I think
he's six two
um because I can see over the top of his
head uh when I'm wearing shoes I don't
get I'm six one um and I'm an only child
it's crazy because she has a similar
experience that I do where her parents
are shorter than her and she's an only
child I'm like are you trying to take my
thing because
my whole family is tall on both sides my
mom is 510 my dad is 6'4 I have an older
brother and he's six three my grandma is
actually the shortest person in my
family and she's five seven also wow can
I ask where you all buy pants Old Navy
Old Navy I'm an Old Navy Stanford if I
go to Old Navy is only because I like I
need pants quick but I know that I'm
still gonna be like two inches short so
I'm gonna be high watering it into
becoming yeah honestly I Thrift a lot
yeah and so it's always like a one by
one case you know scenario you gotta
like look at the bottom of the pants
straight to the men's
feeling about just being tall because
for me you know when you're taller at a
younger age you're deem more mature yes
so I just feel like alongside with like
just people staring it just sucks like
you know as women you know how it is so
yeah I get there's like well I won't say
it happens a lot there was like this one
guy in particular maybe two but he would
come up to me and be like oh well you
know we're the same size laying down
Horrible no the worst pickup line is
like can I climb that tree
I've been getting lately oh let's make a
D1 baby I had this like really bad
memory um at a summer camp where I was
sitting and you know everyone else was
dancing and no one asked me because I
was so tall
um and some guy came up to me and was
asking me to dance and I stood up and I
was taller than him yeah and he was like
oh my bad I didn't realize you were a
man and I was like what you know at that
age that hurt but that name
foreign
okay really quick what's like a unique
experience that like short people
wouldn't have had I have a friend who's
like four foot nine and I was FaceTiming
her the other day and she started
freaking out because she was like oh my
God I can't believe that's your like
daily Vision because my head was like
above the fridge and it didn't occur to
me I was like oh yeah most people don't
see the top of their fridge I mean for
me I think it's just reaching stuff like
my friends are a lot shorter than me so
I just feel like I can just reach a lot
of stuff for them I worked in retail
like when I was in high school so just
being able to help customers like grab
the tallest thing off like the highest
shelf possible like what is a plus for
me when Janelle was talking about
reaching at the top of a shelf where I
was like yeah I do that all the time but
like I'm never reaching at the the most
high shelf of a grocery store like I
can't even reach that so either she's
really really tall or not tall at all
[Music]
oh
I was really surprised they voted me out
because I was bringing a lot of personal
experiences
have you ever done anyone like done
anything to make yourself like not how
do I explain this okay like when I was
not to not to shrink myself but almost
the opposite like when I first went to
college I dyed my hair pink because I
specifically was like I want to be known
as the girl with pink hair and not the
tall girl yeah yeah I actually also had
pink hair at one point
um I think for me it was like if people
are gonna stare at me and they're gonna
fixate on me no matter what I do I'd
rather they remember me for something
that I do
like yeah yes yeah I know for me I
haven't really entered my adult phase
yet right so I'm kind of still in that
teen era so I'm kind of the opposite I
kind of do a lot to like shrink myself
like in photos you'll never catch me
standing up straight unless it's a
basketball photo but um like I'll always
be slouching or like when we when I'm
like with friends I'm always like really
cognizant like how much taller I am than
them so like hopefully someday I'll be
as confident as all of you beautiful you
guys are amazing
it's annoying to be like especially with
my name I have a unique name so if
someone is like oh I was just talking to
Kira the other day like oh the tall one
what other cameras do you know like so
why do you have to add that right I know
that always comes in like I've had
people come after me like in the hall at
school like hey you tall girl hey hey
you I'm like I have a name like there
was one round where Tatiana was a little
quieter and I was like oh is she running
out of things that she's to say I I feel
like you're a shortcut yeah
just say that you're short go ahead
thank you
I had no idea people were suspicious of
me at all I was shocked when I got voted
out you could see it in my face
raise your hand on three one two three
if the Box turns green the four people
split the cash price
I hope y'all are tall I know
please
foreign
[Music]
especially when I turned into her
standing next to me and it was a very
large height difference
up here so she can't read
but it's actually crazy because you guys
are bringing up like a lot of people
bring up stuff about your height and
I've never really thought about that
because I get that a lot with me like
almost on an everyday basis of being
short yeah I have a short friend she's
like five foot sure yeah
so it's like we literally have almost
the same experience it's just flip
different right exactly reverse so it's
like we send each other like tall and
short means you support each other on my
sister she's actually six foot so I
basically took her Persona she gave me
like her whole life story I mean I
already know it because I'm her sister I
felt like I was looking up at a lot of
the women around me I was like this is
amazing I rarely feel this way it was
super empowering to see and meet these
other beautiful women that have
experienced the same things
could you tilt down yeah lower lower
there we go if you enjoyed this video
make sure to like And subscribe to our
Channel and thank you so much to all of
our tall Queens high five
oh
my goodness
extra height hello guys hello